hello the Internet iron gaff welcome to
this slow mo guys video you have to
pardon my appearance my barber is closed
how inconsiderate of him
this video is slightly different because
my co-star is Smee the cat he is a six
year old Siamese and he may look
slightly tired because he spent the
entire day pelting it about the garden
like an absolute lunatic why don't we
take a look at some lovely slow-mo
footage of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you did so well boy you were absolutely
legging it bit clumsy though he does
land on his back an awful lot you're
supposed to land on your feet Smee it's
one of the few things you're supposed to
do it honestly makes me wish that I had
this wicked high-speed camera set when
he was a kid because he was a very cute
and very clumsy kitten and I could have
filmed a bunch of that in slow-mo oh
wait I did this is me his favorite
camera is the Fenton flex as you can see
I'm filming him drink up a little bit of
water a nice sweet
[Music]
well there you have it
slo-mo cap unbeatable Internet in my
opinion
big thanks to Smee the cat who is
suitably exhausted and big thanks to
Turney who helped me run around the
garden like a lunatic hopefully you
enjoyed that video
make sure you subscribe and we'll see
you in the next one who knows what that
one will be about